pour rigoler un peu il ya un truc bon et
naturelle entre qui fait en fait il ya
un scientifique indien via qui a décidé
de faire du gaz lacrymogène écolo par
contre en fait le gaz lacrymogènes mais
pas du tout écolo parce que les dunes
mild hydrid donnant que du mal à lui
trouver des désavantages enfin de ce
fait là qui me gêne
[Musique]
je me suis rendu compte que dans les
publications scientifiques
tout le monde sait que ce gaz
lacrymogènes libère du cnr on a juste
dit que ce n'était pas dangereux parce
que c'était des doses très très faibles
[Musique]
ils disent que la 20 mg par litre tient
aussi à 405 et du sénat c'est normal
pour un fumeur cdc un taux record pour
un film art c'est pas un taux normal
point final
[Musique]
pour avoir des effets très conséquents
sur le foie les reins et le cerveau
notamment
[Musique]
lacrymogènes cerutti ça fait mal ça fait
pleurer normalement ne compensent que
juste que ça fait pleurer mais en fait
ça agit pas sur les larmes ça agit sur
des récepteurs de la douleur
[Musique]
il ya même une étude de bothell qui vous
dit que un policier équipé de spray
lacrymogène se fait beaucoup plus
agressés statistiquement qu'un policier
qui n'est pas équipé d'arbres quand on
se plaint qu'il ya plein de black blocks
qui va de plus en plus bas peut-être
qu'il faudrait faire des choses pour
éviter de générer des black box
[Musique]
c'est rentré dans les moeurs et en fait
on n'a jamais vraiment justifié
l'utilisation de ces gaz lacrymogène et
évaluer à quel point il était dangereux
[Musique]